we're on our way to High Rock one of the
worst-hit towns on Grand Bahama downed
power lines snake across the road which
is only just passable during hurricane
durian it was an ocean it's Dan Kemp
hometown he hasn't been back since the
category 5 storm hit Dan this is the
furthest east you'd be yeah what do you
make of what you see I don't know it's
unbelievable I have never seen thing
like this I may have been through
hurricanes but not like this total
devastation it's a staggering sight we
reached what was the town's
administrative center the police station
smashed open the medical center across
the street bulldozed not by machines but
by nature at its most powerful 500
people lived in High Rock locals told us
40 stage during Dorian 17 of them are
now missing people look stunned the
hurricane left only four days ago
parking here at peak for Sur for 48
hours the roof is gone your sofa is in
the rafters Kenneth appears to be in
total shock that's your brother's
wheelchair yeah he's missing he's
missing he's dead yeah I'm so sorry
Oh
the terror people must have felt in
their final moments is unimaginable
there is no official aid here yet so
people are doing what they can I cannot
let somebody die like that
pastor Cecil Kemp saved his neighbor who
was clinging to this tree other
neighbors are gone forever this is Dan's
daughter returning to what was her
grandparents home they are at least safe
but these salvaged mementos are all they
have now the residents have described to
us how a huge wave came from the north
and swept through this area destroying
everything in its path we'd have been
under water here a couple of days ago
you can see where the water was at the
top of that debris and it was such a
powerful surge that it brought cars that
are now stuck in the debris here in a
whole manner of things across here
chairs TV monitors swept out of people's
homes as even a bottle of aftershave
from a bathroom cabinet everything that
it came through destroyed and brought
out towards the ocean which they can now
see here because everything has been
flattened it's remarkable that anyone or
anything survived these now calm waters
had this town under siege
people are dazed by trauma in desperate
need of food and shelter in this tight
community they're doing what they can
for each other but it's nowhere near
enough dan will return with as many
supplies as he can can High Rock recover
yeah yeah but it's nothing Oh
it's not a nomad
Amanda Walker Sky News High Rock grand
bahama